what's up boo what's up boo
what's a full podcast with Felipe
Esparza and my wife the manager at large
manager of the year March March
Lisa Esparza and our guest today with
Roger Lopez comedian from South Central
right uh West la puesta West LA I was
not here yet
oh yeah well he won't be here today but
if anybody asked him he had a boy his
wife had a boy he is a proud father of
Tomas Tomas Tomas 7-pound step seven
pounds seven ounces of sativa we could
roll him up in a blanket and smoke it so
yeah he's out here Riverside right now
breast and a baby right now can't each
other different I think everybody
started breastfeeding him already he
tell Rodrigo was AdMob that's one of my
my homie just had a kid and in the his
son like try to like suck his titties a
few times because like my homies like
almost 200 pounds but like all right
like you know short whatever what's so
cool oh man shout out to everybody
affected by the the manslaughter the
terrorist attacks yeah the white
surplice yes ma'am my Lisa just left a
room but I'm her arm her brother's son
he um he had just let that bar in date
10-15 minutes before everybody started
shooting lucky man that are lucky he
just made it out there man just in time
me man
like I could smell Trouble Man like
nobody's gonna walk in and show
everybody on my watch
everybody's staying on he's talking [ __ ]
no man I could tell when people are sad
and I see her sad [ __ ] I'll give
him a hug and I'm not getting my
just as I care about here I'm feeling
for rifles haha really enough his body
man that's so tragic you know I feel bad
for everybody I feel bad for that
shooters mom what she has to go through
you know they're probably you probably
can't talk to her neighbors right now I
know the first you got a girl coming
over so your crazy-ass son where did you
go wrong [ __ ] where'd you go wrong cuz
you know where my planes the kids always
been the parents man they should know
what the [ __ ] you started doing but he
should know where he's up to man you
should be talking to him like I hit a
boy I remember I hit a porno and I mom
found it a mile away bro a mile away she
said how she knows yours kids man I
don't know but she follow me probably
dogs she probably Lisa's brother's son
left 50 minutes before it happened right
he left that I used to work at a bar
right across the street from there I
looked outside and I saw the Ned peppers
property it wasn't Ned pepper so that's
by the comedy club right Wiley's yeah
why Lisa's like half a block down the
street from there isn't no let go last
place on the corner like a slaughter
shop in a County we could buy burgers I
don't know if the open door I don't know
there's there's so many businesses that
change it over there but I worked at a
bar called the Charlie Charlie stop that
was there since the 40s I think thirties
had a tin roof or tin ceiling inside but
that was my first bar and right across
the street was that area but it was all
usually college kids who went over there
you know to go to those bars it's just
like a two-block Street with all sorts
of bars and like um little shops and
stuff they each other good area yeah
yeah it's a little condensed little
place I can't imagine all that chaos
going on there cuz they've had
cobblestone streets too like it's still
a small old when they used to have
Charlie's I mean he cracker people we
got here there was a spread out there
like us ready go no no one look man it
was cheese's prosciutto nuts grapes
stuffed peppers
oh man I don't know what it's doing
Arthur Mitchell be in here
like you know kind of stuff oh we have
Roger here hey Roger frost Lester lay
man hell yeah
what's up fool man I've been working
hard man I've been busy
I finished taping that show gente fied
it'll be out in the September sometime
or next month I don't know October but
look out for in the fall I play crazy
Dave also I'm also shooting a new I'll
show Adult Swim I can't really talk
about it but I got Luis Guzman on it
yeah man it's fun man like I said I
don't know people like I have to worry
that out fat Indian chief I have to
worry about the lines you know like
memorizing lines for rows but now that I
realized it man I don't gonna memorize
nothing you gotta have a good movie to
watch wow I take a break I sit there for
like three hours for hours waiting for
my seem to be filmed so in the three
hours I memorize my lines yeah sometimes
I get there at 8:00 in the morning and
then I'll start working 203 and I leave
an APM bro yeah that's just [ __ ] up
being on set sometimes man they have you
wait in the in the green room or the
waiting room for like hours we had him
come early yesterday who's supposed to
have a three o'clock called time and
then they were like 9 o'clock hey can
you come as soon as possible so we get
there as soon as possible he waits until
3:30 I don't care man I rather sit there
and wait they be locked up and waiting
again nothing yeah that's true
I love waiting because I get paid so
we're gonna you bring our stuff yeah I
was on HBO's Westworld season 2 I was a
indian teenager I think I saw you bro
HBO's yeah you were acting or extra no
just an extra like part of that family
that he keeps revisiting the native
second family and then Clifton is it
clifton collins jr. yeah he's in it too
right are you part of his family
I'm American guy III just he was on set
like what's his name I don't know his
name Brody Fargo was he in Fargo that's
cool yeah I was talking to this one dude
named Little Bear on set I like the
whole two days he was like 69 but he'll
barely 50 Wow how did you work on the
west-world
only two days you know open the
mountains in Piru it was it was cold as
[ __ ] it was like Piru is 36 degrees I'll
open the mountains and then they were
like bro here put like just take off my
clothes just this other [ __ ] you know by
magic mountain huh yeah hey not too far
away yeah Piru
what are you shop I rule okay there's a
highway right at the one that's the 126
there's another mountain in that area
there's another studio there and they
shoot every cheap Vietnam movie they're
like when I was working there I showed
up I worked on a show called um it's an
old show on HBO called Vietnam war
stories I don't even know if it was ever
on it was an early 80s and now they also
shot then other show from CBS there was
a Vietnam show and the other show where
they were nursing or doctors China Beach
China Beach was shot there yeah I've
been a little before my time man never
heard one you probably yeah yeah I think
it was like 90 when I was finishing high
school 90 yeah dude Offshore's you know
yeah it was called this [ __ ] shot mash
there oh I know mash man not an issue
but they showed over 18 there yeah they
have that's a one thing about growing up
man everybody had a gun that's a team
like ba Baracus mr. t that who had a
platinum ak-47 that never shot no one
right everybody eat up and every time we
push somebody literally up the sky
Martin Rizzo jeshoda martini use his old
life to get here from his car
how's it going guys what's up ooh how
this get older in you bro younger than
you why is it because uh the Luxor no
age oh yeah you're like what 20 to 25
you're 37 no no no sounds plugged up oh
yeah
Braille it look like my age two brothers
like you say you're younger than Phillip
oh man he looks just like Phil oh yeah
yeah how long do you guys started how
long did we start ago ten minutes but uh
nobody was in Westworld Oh here in West
world yeah season two I was in the
episode got a horse I did it but you
know who's [ __ ] up bro they had like
the only white person on set had blue
eyes and they gave him like a fake wig
and he was in charge of the horses I was
like we couldn't get it another than
native to get that job oh right but
there was around like at least like 20
30 40 was the actual trainer though for
the horses ah nah there was this older
other older white actor he was acting he
was an actor in it but like I'm like
that's kind of weird they couldn't find
another Native American there's a
there's like a bunch of us here should I
ask the bro stop HBO
wait a West roles based off the movie
West world right from like yeah yeah and
West worth based of Jurassic Park yeah
original West world the original West
world movie it's the same and it's the
same premise for Jurassic Park like that
same idea that he watched the West world
original and then what was a party to
the similarities like what the original
Michael Crichton crack you the original
one is like the the robots go crazy
right they go off well
yeah it's more that they miss far they
go haywire they want yeah but in this
one in the HBO series they're actually
learning oh they're like artificial
intelligence it's a little more like no
not Logan's Run it's more like um what's
the movie with Rutger Hauer and
Oh Bladerunner sentient recipes to Riga
Howard I had the best scene in Beirut on
his time when he finally realizing that
he's talking to dad I could his side
boards were made to live for like a
certain amount of time yeah so he house
a stark realization that he's gonna die
so we're trying to find the person I
made up to give more life yeah he was at
a time and then like he that yeah the
last conversation as I that's a drawing
drawing joint right there as a droid to
a human being so um it's the first time
he he stopped being um he realized he's
human yeah he's also dying so he had a
conversation before he came with he
don't want him to die he makes her sit
there and they're like Rutger Hauer
brags about what he's seen in his life
yeah and in the end line was all these
memories was gonna be lost like a fart
in the wind way that's that he don't
stay far too windy something now but
something like that noesis like tears in
a way know it drop it in an ocean or
something like and then the Dove sits on
his lap could be Eliza he's a human man
a robot oh cool bro is wack yeah you
find out that out it was just always
been a block he's a robot
no he's a hunter he's like a like a
hunter to a buddy
hunts down the ones road yeah it was
just almost a flying this patient or the
flying low rider bro but he's not he
there is no other Latino reverence I
think that's just you thinking oh that
looks like I believe about averages
almost leaves origami ax next to you
that means you're dead oh yeah always
like he's yeah I think I seen that I
remember we saw that part of it looks
like a lowrider cuz we were talking
about you're talking you see a lot they
know in space yeah there were Jimmy
Smith and star
as cars all like decked out his face
cars yeah parking ticket beginning of us
see those torture we're putting a boot
on it yeah what's up fool
yes man um somebody I've got a question
here that your um my herpes Oh Marcin
herpe that's older than he should
oh man this weekend I was chilling right
and it activates me up Rudy Youngblood
hmm
no that is man your father bro hahaha is
a male actor from Apocalypto Jaguar paw
he a sure who's your higher yeah yeah
yeah dudes oh dang else cry I'm looking
exactly like that fool when I come off
the pool I just like my oh my head like
down people told me bro you look like
you're out of a pocket lift on my thank
you you get hired for a bro we just
finished eight edward james olmos and
you spa there Edgar J Edgar Allan Allan
Poe almost broke brat did in once upon a
time in China
hey guys cool Rudy Youngblood I was cool
yeah I was a great movie bro party he's
never hit me up he was a man I grew up
in them in in Belton Texas by Killeen
and I saw your performance I saw a
performer they are like what the [ __ ] so
I hit him up we talked on a phone left
for an hour I thought I was like your
brother or somebody cuz you're talking
for a long time dr. Brock caught him
right now though and it's not going to
the show dude yeah two shows dude go to
Comic Con pull the nipple hey do it
sound Felipa there's a lot of people
that like only they like one movie and
they milk it and they have like their
booze and I'll do this guy got
recognized sold like so much more than
like the guy may have a home booth oh
yeah they got from Terminator look carry
the read it get it yeah recognize so
much although we had trouble selling
didn't know you could merely go another
$2,000 during the day and they're your
other comedy money
it's crazy cuz like you got more
recognizing like the other people cuz
like what's it called people are like
contending pictures of you I even know
who you work though who's that guy you
know I just want to get in on it yeah we
got the comic-con and Kelleen there was
a black man with family leaving and they
gave us that man gave up his three-day
pass now it's so cool man pass so I give
that for twenty bucks
now he get with a heart pretty well he
gave me the heart of $50 yeah every 20
bucks probably more than a dude I see I
love getting to events like it and then
the way out I saw this graph with old
lady grandma with a little white kid and
I gave it to her
a happy bro she give me no money we were
in there we saw [ __ ] Damien
shoutout to Damien chopped up from blood
and blood out and street fighter me Glow
was there
Wow he was cool huh he's gonna be so
looks the same as he there you know
there's the same man 20 years he was
happy man he was too laughing at the
colonel you got hit in the butter on
that one usurping out that he sorry
there's what though all we also saw that
black actor from WKRP in Cincinnati Tim
Reid nobody knows also the shield of the
sister from The Fresh Prince the Hillary
Hillary was there and the mom the second
mom the second second man light-skinned
oh yeah in the 25 bucks is I was trying
like film for afar with it you can't
take pictures cuz you got to pay 25
bucks that's why they make their money
and then Kevin Sorbo was there sold out
what was the most expensive photo to
take I think you know service was his
dirty bucks I think Bam Margera was
there too but he missed his flight cuz
on TMZ like the same day I saw that he
got arrested
you got a wrestler you went crazy off
what's the call at the airport yeah
solidly he made them there make it yeah
yeah
today managers to [ __ ] it all to be
getting that guy's crazy
yeah 553 try for three pouring you were
there three Power Rangers hero the
original black Ranger the bridge I had a
peak Ranger and the blue one yeah Oh si
there how do you know they were not in
their uniform all of the whole show
right I never watch that show but so I
was gonna say how do you know there's a
Jersey i clamp yeah like after in the
middle of school or something yeah yeah
they they skipped a lot class I never
saw one episode but I've seen a lot of
fights yeah never seen when I have no
idea how its structure is it just me or
did the Blue Ranger do a lot of math
when I was an addict Michael Parker on
the show is not always burning beer so
you could go anyway so know that the
White Ranger of Jeor Perez will new the
block up in prison he locked up with him
wrong
really huh haha damn fool the White
Ranger we're in a boat and pretending
we're gonna buy a bull for somebody and
kill the guy throw him off the boat oh
yeah I heard about the air profile was
[Music]
no problem Chicago Parker arm those are
birth show ISM every Monday no no birth
show is the cooking show and
bilborough's every Monday don't forget
all right fool have a good day boom
what's up bruh what you doing comedy yet
I started doing it at The Comedy Store
my first spot four years ago whoo yeah I
was like twenty like two weeks from
turning 21 and I had a fake ID I was
using for like 19 or 20 it was my homie
who looked like me but you know he was
like two Illyrio maja yeah like all the
way here yeah did you get it too close
with that ID yeah I would I saw
schoolboy q my first rap concert in
nineteen it was like a free concert and
then a man of the year just came out and
yeah it was cool man there was like a
lot of finance Asian chicks but I was
like a little [ __ ] back then you know I
wasn't my girl yeah it was out of those
globalist Oh
I'll remember that by sorting yeah it's
still over that's cool that's been a
borderline hipster place for a long time
right like it's like vicita where it has
its paisa crowd and then it has a
hipster white crowd and hipster Latino
crown too right like in the front Globus
is the same way right yes yeah just
Spanish nice mm-hmm
cuz we [ __ ] that everybody that went
through a global who are Park anyway I
live in Echo Park oh yeah you wouldn't
know as far away though right yeah
that's super low-key I would park in the
hills right to the left of los globos
you're thinking about you
Bahia yeah go by here manga grind it on
every year mom well so um I made you
into a 2121 ya know in a 1999 what the
[ __ ] you know 2009 so 21 yeah and then
you were in a role in 2010 huh yeah with
you yeah mausi everyone I I told you
that like my mouth was tripping RF right
she's like like what are you doing this
is a hold a guy like we're gonna go to
hotels together I'm gonna Barton Rizzo's
Barton she didn't know she didn't know
and they after that when she saw the
paychecks they all right that's funny
than like when you when he came over to
the house that first time that's what
you had a you were doing a DAB right
I never seen those machine although it
was I had a whip on it was a [ __ ]
whip like the hose and so Martin walks
in and he immediately grabbed the hose
and went like this to kind of creep
Martin out you say are you ready to go
on the road
Nino's bro every week hahaha and the
Martin was like like and then he sounds
livid that one of his homies that he
grew up with Oh Papa he worked at my
hospital run your weed in my high school
remember he was a he was a guy that was
in charge of the locker the boys locker
room so I remember like every time I
walk in if we always talked me my
friends and we would talk about
we would talk about porno and he was old
but he was like you must be like
30-something and were teenagers we
talked about porno you know like yeah
corner with him yeah you talk about
girls I know and then after that what's
the guy remember I way we take a picture
the 4th of July picture with you guys
and net it up I'll say hey that's my as
Martin Matt I know that guy's Oh small
world you break into a locker yeah they
broke into my locker so I thought we had
to use the loners shorts in the loner
uniform so that's what we became good
friends one more on yeah that's rough us
the musician right you going up with a
pervert
no no I remember she was scared I'm off
felt the same way when I was going to
like Rosarito I was driving I worked at
a dry cleaners and then the owner was a
64 year old gay white dude and his
friend was like the he basically I was
just driving down to Rosarito he go [ __ ]
like for like a hundred bucks he felt
like well you driving down to Rosarito
yeah he'd paid me like 350 I mean I
translate he pay all the food all that
[ __ ] he own the dry cleaning that you
worked at yeah and then you this was a
side job he hired you for
on the weekends yeah but like my mom was
like watch out because I once we got to
Rosarito he do there I was just kicking
it but he was [ __ ] like 18 year olds
and [ __ ] like 60 boys yeah more money
yeah he would pay him like 180 and then
I get Mexico that's like $1,000 oh damn
yeah yeah some homologies I'd be careful
man you'll know what's up I might now be
alright oh man he offered me like three
months working out the drycleaners
warias let me see it so we go to
Rosarito we get to the hotel we get to
like the chicken and then he looks at me
he's like one or two bedrooms I'm like
yeah
like - of course right loose love next
to him yeah my two bedrooms right he's I
reluctantly all right but then he starts
talking like in a low voice like the the
receptionist and then when we go
upstairs like you know we get like he's
like ballin so we get like the top floor
is beautiful there as soon as we open
the door to the hotel it's like one room
oh and I'm like yo what the [ __ ] he's
like what bro you know what my other
co-workers you know they slept with me
in the bed before I'm like and the same
very what and I'm like that's cool
brothers then they known you five years
brother I've known you barely three
months yeah maybe five years I hear ya
nah and then I was like brother man was
sleep outside in the couch he he's like
really he got super upset
damn and then I was like you know what
if any I'll sleep on the balcony words I
used the overlooking rosarito beach
house I I sleep out here it's beautiful
and he's like are you serious you're not
gonna steal me the same bed I'm like no
what the [ __ ] is what are you thinking
and then of cookie bro yeah bro and then
dad would have broken that night haha
Nike then he went down he got like two
bedrooms and I was like this is cool and
then down the line when I was at the dry
cleaners like I would I would go
upstairs to the office and then he play
yo Roger he like these shirts are stiff
[Laughter]
I'll give you ten G's it's like my dude
I was like what no I'll give you a 5 or
that you suck mine that's the thing
though brother so you want to eat or
something to attend college yeah yeah
but you know a funny man is like when I
hear these three like what made you
think that you will go for it like
trying results that would you to him bro
nah I think this is his game bro he
would only hire like straight man
good-looking guys like a pixel vote and
then he hired us like there was no
females basically working at the drugs
all the like to order like Latina ladies
and then the deal changes a group all
like three months later we will need
when he said like here's $10,000
I wonder so my day she stayed you laugh
and say hello
I was like yeah [ __ ] no bro he was but
he always said in a joking way boy he
put a dollar in my hair now we went down
put his past down and he posed to share
the he'll meet your own ride home
when I was in Nam when I was there and
I'm Killeen Texas our neighbor of my
name whether they call him whether he
had a brother named chewy and needs to
live next to this guy named Pete and
after guy that seemed like you bro like
except that it worked for him I showed
up to his house Cheerilee and [ __ ]
he knew everybody that was under he put
it in hand inside my shirt bra creepy
style how much other was it in you for
the old man probably 55 [ __ ] I was like
wow I don't know but rubbing my stomach
and then he took a like some money goes
and I look at the money I just don't
have just drag my ass
yeah and he goes we could do it a little
table like you know like talking about
business-wise nobody has to know then I
said I'm good and I put his hand away
and I went outside okay so I told that
to my neighbor that guy ran into Kelly
he never turn against you you know you
find out when his typing you got to
close so pro why went to so we got older
bro my name my friend was Native
American and they drank every day and
then like and then like so my friend
Ruben khatoun he was sitting down and
then he woke up and I got robbing him
bro like Robert is growing finally woke
up what the [ __ ] and then like and then
my other eye was sudden everybody that
let's say remembers him for doing that
remember oh he was looking at my cousin
and I said well this for trying to give
me five
whoa we beat the [ __ ] outta here bro
like Peter [ __ ] here a bucket toss
that put through a window it's a wicked
officer to beat their asses oh you
beautiful sons for being older male a
particulars yeah come on Paulie he put
him a lesson all his friends or just
chosen loneliest ones yeah yeah the one
who I was always like the outsider like
choose the kids with no parents yeah and
I was never a part of a crew so they'll
never I never had a potential hey don't
go with him all the way walking with
myself
yeah Dan dude everybody was a nasty ass
video man me a much of Brazil a hardcore
video man what he talkin him those are
full sleeping and then his enemy showed
up like it right there are known enemies
and he started punching he [ __ ]
punched up for this sleep bro like
Porsche dog [ __ ] outta here asleep
gilma nother one and let started put you
the [ __ ] out of his stomach bro all in
his sleep yeah he wake up he will go
crying I was sleeping anybody does that
[ __ ] to me brother but I'm a Killa bro
yeah yeah like you waking up even just
man I remember when a story at the movie
theaters there's this one guy his name
was at an Estill well you know I was
when I first got hired as like 18 and
where this guy is my first job after
high school and this guy was very like
weird man this guy what's it called he
got he got fired for sexual harassment
but I think this guy was confused I
don't know which one you like is number
110 we will clean Moyers by ourselves
and one time he [ __ ] cornered me he
cornered me he was bigger than me he
cornered me and he was like try yeah
like an accent he was trying like touch
my he was like trying touch my dick you
know he's like my team my team yeah he's
like that and after that he's like look
at my dick and like I see through his
pants like it is things like going up
like this and oh my god do I [ __ ]
sock the love I [ __ ] hi sock the moms
like what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah
sorry I'm sorry ya know I punched them I
suck them up how does I punch them a
couple times then after like don't you
[ __ ] ever do that again Ernesto
cornered you at work like yeah we're in
ER cuz we clean him with us by ourselves
and after I when I when I punched them
up he never talked to me like that again
and then after a couple a month later I
hear they got fired for like I want to
grow bent over to pick up some ice
he grabbed their ass so I guess you just
didn't know what you liked you know he
was just like everything yeah yeah
anybody who gave him attention yeah my
son a continue I'm working at that it
with a mood me to movement they pay a
lot of grab-ass definitely a sexual
assault it was sexual assault yeah I had
my broom in my house got the little man
yeah Osman I remember when I'd be like
in Koreatown all right yeah well [ __ ] I
used to live there I might see like
little by Cesare like shitty cars and
they would like pick up like guitar
what's it called what's it called Lata
hookers you know that we're guys might
dress like girls and like they were just
going in there and they'd be like I know
they know they know well you know they
know that it's a guy you know and it
would drive off yeah yeah everybody I
was like Eddie Murphy bro picked up that
transgender over at Hollywood and
Highland and several little boy they
don't care they're just worn you know
they just want to know when ice to work
at Dodger Stadium I was like 16 17 years
old and I'll get off at midnight 11:30
and catch the bus probably on Broadway
bro yeah south we probably what Broadway
and just broad way across the street
fund that by Carl's jr. dirty so a
little
Oh jr. right yeah I closed jr. right
there needs to be a Mexican restaurant
and first I was eating there and then
saw who showed up he asked me for a bite
from fine I just cut a little Peter put
it in here and they're like and they're
like so I see you know what I'm hanging
now at this area right so many losers
here I think for money and crack behind
me so [ __ ] a I made a big mistake
I want to go catch the bus on first and
Broadway it is [ __ ] dark
yeah like 16 years old right I waited
there are full of van pulled up a van
and it was like some guy who looked like
the lead singer love boo keys bro oh
like Ice Cube if you look Mexican right
ha ha ha and he goes hey kid who's right
there now you want a ride he opens door
and everything thought I didn't look in
their help money like a bear in the van
bro rains will just tear up your little
booth and then throw in Elysian Park but
I said nah man I'm good for this [ __ ]
bus [ __ ] you so that's what well but I
was stupid like I could have like I
could have just I could have just taken
the bus to I don't know you know I could
think in the bus with different routes
yeah but that's where the bus dropped me
off
no cat that [ __ ] when they catch water
by 11:15 yeah but it was dirty dude I
can't believe how many how many man
wanted a Kimmy a ride
it's surprising how much stuff you guys
have come in contact with I got hit by a
lot of guys in my life I mean it always
happens to girls like you have a gross
gross out story like every year Joseph
and terminus no no I'm talking about
guys but like some guys are so surprised
that guys act like this but I feel like
a lot of guys go through this at some
point in their teenage years you know
[Laughter]
for that we start to winter snake and no
guy touched my crotch and
green light and 0 when I was sitting
down one time on the bus there was a
[ __ ] old white man like he must have
been old bro who reached over and
grabbed my leg and I'm okay
he tried uh poquito stay balanced you
know but he would never you just want
somebody but then it had started sliding
and I said madness but I told my side if
you touched my dick I'm not talking
about the window flying out of here why
should I wait that long
yeah you know should you stay a stopper
you pervert crazy I know what happened
out cuz he might be balancing himself
yeah you don't want to miss read that ya
know there was a guy on there gross guys
on the bus and the trains and stuff man
cuz I used to take when I was in jury
duty for that long as month at one time
it took forever I would take the bus
home to Echo Park from downtown and
there was this guy who rode the bus at
that same time and he would look at
women's legs and feet so if you had you
know open-toed shoes on or your legs
exposed in a skirt or something he would
look at me and he'd start haha and he'd
start like moving his legs you know like
squeezing his legs that's a whole new
level
yeah he was you would do that and I and
I was so grossed out once I realized
what he was doing and I I would try to
get the next bus after him because I
knew he always got like the 315 you know
whatever so know we're gonna have a good
time I'm wearing that brand new Levi his
bro yeah harder boots are squeezing your
balls that is a lot of work bro yeah
yeah like thunder thighs but there's a
lot louder purrs huh
yeah dude specially the library when
you're like crossing people specific I'm
apology goes out what when he went I was
kicked over in order to a comedians
house and then I got all over a comedian
but they were the same age and they were
smoking weed and then he goes hey Paul I
like you that's cool you know I like you
too many cool
over smoke weed oh wait I know I know it
I really really like you who left and
now whose - around dog very so yeah I
think berry took his dick out when I
gave him right huh I'm not sure about
that well [ __ ] it's crazy
I blocked them out for the house I get
the [ __ ] out my car what's out here bud
marcher drizzle and dirty Roca showed up
[Laughter]
let's go on the road you know I'm when I
was like yeah I'm down when he do he
asked me like you look like a sticker
I bet was veiny huh I don't know bro he
I don't want to talk about it man shoots
weirdest [ __ ] you get home alright
holding you I gave him a ride home yeah
we hit like an open mic here you know we
went to the valley into a PT's place it
was cool as you know sure Mike yeah bro
we were just joking weed you know not
the way it looked like I gave him a ride
home we were going up Laurel and then
you know he was just being super weird
bro he's always weird yeah he's so rude
man yeah he's like Roger Rabbit if you
came to like you kind of had this bigger
than life characters yeah and then he
just driving on Mulholland Drive
no no Laura that's a yeah it was weird
bro he was like putting his phone down
by his like his crotch or he was like yo
Trent look at this on my brother Ivan
and
you know I was almost years ago I was
doing that skateboarding thing we had
yeah yeah yeah then I thought it was
cool cuz you know you had you know
[ __ ] I'm like you know I saw your
didn't warn anybody I heard stories but
I've never never done anything you know
like that you know so I'm not sure cuz I
was like yeah people probably just lying
but then I heard other stories oh okay
cool yeah yeah bro yeah and then when I
stopped bugging him he started [ __ ]
with his other dude that was from India
you can't look like me - I was like I
felt bad for the dude over or hairstyle
so blonde no yeah that's happened we
that's TP with to Hollywood in the 80s
for 90 more huh
well show you later I'll watch your
losses spooky it's wrong ro that she's
really good today yeah yeah as you see
Panchito I saw first episode I see
Panchito photos any Panchito bro and
whanau they got they get hired again to
do another show but then the little
Panchito hire them for to be a scary huh
but when he there he just being a
pervert bro watching them yeah he wants
them all dressed up like monsters and
then they show up and they're like oh
wait you're just a pervert
funny could that gross - were in a
burrito her monstrous
The awkward yeah the one who has all the
odd jobs to any job role later Raja by
the bunch of sports drinks she also
tries out people's shoes bro shoes like
flipping the fan like I was like
nobody-nobody those valet guys they
speak English right he's only but and I
think they're in Mexico because they
have an ambassador it could probably be
maybe the border yeah it's funny how a
fred armistice character he all his life
he didn't want to be a badly yeah little
kid he was there with friends oh he will
drive girls around just to partner to
show this parking skills yeah yeah it's
a great show it's so original and it's
just I love that it's in Spanish you
don't care like and everybody still
loves it yes the whole Spanish and the
whole subtitles gives it kind of like a
foreign film kind of feel but it feels
very American yeah at the same time
again via they all think and act like
their American culture wise yeah but
also Mexican well we don't even know
Mexican I don't know if it's but but
yeah because they're in I guess
California or United States when he's
parking when he's working
I'm thinking maybe it could be like San
Diego and TJ something like that yeah
yeah yeah we were moving Killeen Texas
will be performing at twice as funny
clown comedy lawn chair it was a black
home club huge are that place do it's it
looks like it's like boy ready to
[ __ ] take atomic bombs over again
gonna get there it looks like we're
there a high for walkers yeah yeah it's
that far it you like the the
rural areas yeah there was like when you
go when you were showing the video
stories of it oh my god this place looks
like a deserted bowling alley or
something yeah you said Roadhouse right
yeah Road House like nothing happens
there like that please took a change I
love telling somebody they need to be
like a regular club you know though a
regular Club and then like someone got
shot and killed right outside not
outside but down the street coming from
leaving that place then it shut down
then I became a play with hip-hop and
country at the same time yeah and then
the comedy club open okay
it's like everybody knows each other in
that town shots shots job yeah
I was giving a ride to these girls I
live in Catalina Island and they said
that's only a Mercedes only a mile and
there's only one high school one mall
and everybody knows each other there
yeah that's what sure it's a it's a
Latino yeah and like you can't drive a
car out there cuz there's no [ __ ]
space you can only golf carts go by yes
so we turned sixteen theater a big
family you just can't have a big family
no I go on walks yeah yeah it's like
China you're gonna have one kid haha
Friday night they had a they had the
funniest guy from the open might perform
and what open Mikey so he wasn't up
there bro like he like he like Birdman
or over there yeah yeah every every time
is the Birdman yeah yeah yeah huh y'all
have him who goes up there it was chance
and you're like what I saw and a Jersey
and a hat yeah idea and then they ask me
man hey man look at the photos - Open
Mic month the promoter want the owner
wants to put it put put him out to his
audience I say well it's gonna be clean
bro get the [ __ ] up the stage at five
that's it
oh so never get back ah and then it all
right I spoke to him I said I'm all
right man you know I have all those oh
that dirty you know so just because it
to you if I'm gonna be clean bring it
off and that's what I let that then I
told him that I'll or if you have clean
five minutes you're gonna get a lot of
work didn't get it dude
he didn't want to be clean didn't get it
but it was clean though his wife was hat
like so happy she was all proud
our property lady for some guy some
gather the pulley hook to go a weed and
that we were full of thorns brawl a
thorn I'm gonna make Jesus proud about a
quarter I thought you read throughout my
neck nailed myself breaking up the weed
bro
and like when he give it to me a break
hey har bro and then the next day you
brought to do that brought the Windigo
but ya think that we'd brought honestly
of the work we'd never had oh boy oh
bleep oh yeah he also has chance with
this - yeah and in a Texas football
jersey and a cowboy hat bro
Hank I was a character dude yeah then he
goes oh man okay my toes but that was
not my real - really
you had hungry man make it up to you
guys no I got everything fully we went
to his car and he came back with our
table who bring a pizza cuz it was like
a Pizza Hut bag you know they keep the
pizza warm yeah yeah gyro bag was inside
that fool had [ __ ] um barbecue baked
beans a Tupperware here ribs yeah
[ __ ] macaroni and cheese yeah he
sells plates to food he only saw bad
weed but he sells plates of food for $10
on viagra - I remember you're such a
character cuz like you was even a
community it's just like yeah I got
everything he was like doing these moves
like a Viking like a cartoon character
you know what did you ever watch Atlanta
yeah the Asian guy who rolls up that one
episode he rolls up and he's like he's
on like a little Segway not Segway but
one of the little
hoverboards important he rolls up into
their space and he's like talking about
all sorts of hustles he's good he's a
promoter and he does this yes this and
he's like hahaha
let's take a selfie and it's for
something some product that he's
promoted everything and that sounds like
what that's what they go whoa
yeah yeah yeah like plates of food that
do that's awesome right there and that
place do they have a spread for us right
so are we all the head of orders with
fried pickles fried pickles it was weird
and then how is it private to assault
yeah yeah and then the border patrol
cars I was just no no the Border Patrol
part in the hotel room the whole time
were they're like what the [ __ ] poor he
never moved there to scare people
yeah it's good message away yeah it was
crazy I was like what the [ __ ] is that
was like a joke or something like a prop
car never seen a bordo so a cheering
wife but there was no Mexicans over
there man no man up or Ricans okay
that's what's a Latinos at least yeah
I'll put Ricans a Panamanian legal port
I mean legal they weren't there for the
electricity yeah I was tripping out
there's a Lala Porto Ricans out there I
don't know man that's crazy yeah [ __ ]
we spreading everywhere brought Latinos
everywhere yeah man
then then we went to comic-con and man
we saw a lot of characters out there oh
I figured out who that guy was the one I
was just like Hank Hank you know for
yeah Hank you know he was just like Hank
and that video game that Hank place Oh
Pro payment okay yeah yeah nobody got it
nobody that's the words only nobody gets
your costume at comic-con I we saw a
Wonder Woman Wonder Woman's we didn't
babylegs spar no no no Deadpool Deadpool
yeah baby like this is so funny
then we saw these two world details bro
like white chicks over like Hitler
fifties there were two Broke Girls oh
yeah yeah they're gonna be kinda lazy
too or
Dana girl and Power Girl whatever
thought did you what's up I wasn't
telling you so what how many more
penises every
dick on Friday in the main room this
forgotten blood naked room or neighbors
the comic yeah yeah and I do from Rose
better right yeah right the way we like
this yeah ball he's like generally yeah
bro that [ __ ] was crazy bro so like he
tells audience like all right man it's
late night if you guys want to leave you
guys can leave so he goes to the back
and then he comes with he comes in like
a green like spandex and no t-shirt and
a ukulele right and then he's like he
does that thing and he's IRA if you guys
want to leave again you guys can leave
I'm gonna go in the back for a minute he
comes back outside the second time but
[ __ ] naked I'm like what the [ __ ] bro
bro the [ __ ] sound guy immediately
was like yo brah you can't do that like
they shut off the light and then the the
manager two different yeah he was like
you can't do that because we sell liquor
here you can't be naked it's like same
rules as a strip club like you know and
he was like oh my bad my bad
and then he got dressed again he goes oh
I didn't mean to do it and I was like
what because that place is all corporate
now yeah super corporate it was leverage
bros [ __ ] layers I wanted funny funny
what are you do it for who the laughs
yeah just for the lashes like he was
doing the late like the the last spot on
the at the store so he was in an hour so
like halfway to the hour he is our I'm
we get but Nick and there was not that
many people in the or not the main room
or the main room yeah yeah there was
like people scattered around the whole
on the main room it was crazy I serve
our no the connoisseurs was dead like
nobody was there like when it was like
it's not like what it is now you know
but down over to the main room cuz there
was nobody there and you play the piano
brother dark [ __ ] we beamed up to
your beard I thought Andy Kaufman he
wearing a BA bro you're really crazy
did you ever have you don't kill Tony oh
yeah I did it three times like my 10th
I'm on on stage I did a kill Tony did
the actual stand up yeah I did
yeah how'd it go it went well my first
my 10th say well was a I forget what I
was talking about man
but it was cool man hello Doug Benson
gave me like you know fist bump and
joint not sure you was looking at you
with that eye
you grew up in that southerly West LA
like the shitty part of Culver City I
like to say was it pretty gangster
yeah the outside my building like none
of the Crips lived I lived in a creep
neighborhood ha ha and none of them
lived in my building but they chose the
front of my building as headquarters oh
so there was just like at least like
five Crips all [ __ ] day in front of my
building dad didn't live there now none
of them lived amount of cops now well I
we used to have a manager that live in
the biggest apartment like number Tommy
Hicks bro when I was like I was playing
Nintendo what the managers kids were all
like 12 years old right bro then I hear
like the my homies mom and then their
dad like go outside and then I go
outside now bro they the the moms trying
to get the dad not to go for it the
Crips outside with your bison now it was
a black dude so just you know and then
they I saw like I told you so I saw the
manager at my building right there
[ __ ] yeah he got a [ __ ] kicked by one
of the Crips it was like a legit fight
so that's healing a Heights
let's ginika Heights exactly yeah we
commented that yeah I like to large oh I
see the crib oh it's a large yeah yeah
let's see a [ __ ] Heights was so food
this weekend I'm in Naples Florida off
the hook comedy club August 9 311 shout
out to cut them Brian I'll be there with
Johnny and March and Rizzo San Jose
California San Jose improv August 16 to
the 18 I'll be there with Johnny Rizzo
and Rachel Wulff see also uh Riverside
oh yeah August 13th is Riverside
August 13 Riverside show in Spanish
McAllen Texas are performing at the
Performing Arts Center August 23rd
Lubbock Texas Lubbock Memorial Civic
Center August 24th
Philadelphia PA helium comedy club
August 30 to September first
the air shows coming up
I gotta show us Tim Burton that the
bangbang room in downtown LA and then my
homie runs like the best open mic on
Saturdays it's a behind the Food For
Less on Venice and Western called the
garage Mike attend a garage yeah yeah
yeah the hoods like almost south-central
like yeah it's open mike weir it's a
behind behind in the alley behind the
food for less time Venice and Western
right there yeah by iconic by that sound
freeway yeah right buddy you're gonna
get whacked did a show there at a VFW
mmm in that area well [ __ ] you know it's
a sketchy as there you're like every
every open mic there's always a child
like that rolls by here's a where y'all
from and then we all have to be like
we're comedians we're and and then
they're like all right this is so-and-so
hood and then they used driver do you
make sure you know living in um when I'm
living in downtown right there on
Boylston I didn't know you're there but
on Boylston and
Temple Street and they see better I guys
they're from Diamond Street I don't know
what that mystery was and now fan all at
one time
I think I thought that was telling a
bakery and then something like this
22-year old troll over 21 year old troll
oh I straight up short over on a bald
head
pants were up high white t-shirt he just
stands there in front of the [ __ ]
bakery mad dog and everybody dan I
thought y'all let's do this dude in
there bro mad dog and everybody and um
let's say to myself if I were fall out
the wagon I guess I buy drugs from that
guy
doctor first did I get to my buyer dog
oh if I ever fall off the wagon
I'm gonna buy drugs oh yeah and I ended
up dying from him and his older brother
oh that dude and his brother is waiting
for you to [ __ ] me back I never seen so
buddy more so so much hatred to Isis bro
he buys us they hated their bro like
they hated them they were in a
neighborhood they hate it they were
there speaking Spanish like dude once I
was talking to the older brother and he
goes hold on homey you just mad dog that
Python his family he was
and it turns around and I full stops his
foot and front him like hit a rabbit
room no I spun each no he stopped his
[ __ ] way like he stomped his foot bro
that's some gangster ass [ __ ] right
there bro like a batter who mad dog near
the guy and the guy mad dog him back and
I first stopped his foot
it was so homey Chicanos homey
ok no no no you told a tablet of
Chicanos that's crazy come on bro we are
the same well now brought up with
hardcore dog back to Empire now yeah but
the other 2004 2003 everybody will end
up hating it you know dad you know but
now poor buster but straight up like I'm
pretty sure this fool like was taxing
anybody with a side business in that
area yeah in taco truck or a [ __ ] now
what it was that will go in there bro
and and then like not only would they
hang out right there but at 3 o'clock to
a 4 o'clock they'll be like 10 of them
at a bus stop and he returned a bus stop
they'll be like don't go in there bro
and look around it come on the other
side of the bus the cholos looking for
gay looking for enemies yeah I remember
I'm watching that video of like that
crazy gang meeting in Hollenback Park
well like all the gangs met up do you
see that
I was a VW no hollaback Park all these
gangs made off like all he's like you
know again yeah yeah I was like [ __ ]
like the Mexican [ __ ] uh warriors
they all forget made up hahahaha that
was a crazy video dude yeah nobody but
bald heads Oh like damn I remember high
school do my prom it uh we went to an
after party and it got stopped because
uh guys pulled out guns it's our [ __ ] in
their school or they were other people
because this heist continued in high
school I wanted to also get
continuations yeah so they said on
without all the bad kids you remember
like you know I do remember that it was
like like they had like the space next
to the high school yeah it was consumer
rumor regular high school all the bad
kids like the like the cholos or the
girl that got pregnant it disappeared
and
what happened to them that's really all
we're outside of California I don't
think it's called continuation school
and it's not you don't think it's just
like a dull high school they don't call
it continuation I don't know what that
was when I first moved here and there
aren't that many of them in other places
but there's a lot there's a lot here
yeah we're kind of we know that growing
up like we were pregnant there was a
little special welfare office occasional
school like these premature which are
prenatal care I know it's hard to get
funds and out of a platform wig and
education yeah even though to have that
do I was jumping up my lady that I could
lose the pony car no reason baby boy I
music any pepino and he told me his car
but I probably stole him bro but I was
okay
here I will borrow his stolen car huh
and then take her to school and then
pick her ass up like she was there was
like she was 17 when she was there as
twelve year old 13 yo fortune your girls
are pregnant must be like oh the sink is
my high school you that's where all the
pregnant chicks went and remembered it
was so ghetto that like cholos from
other schools will jump the fence and
[ __ ] people up and then leave like the
only girl at school they just like jump
in there like laughs crazy boy it was
crooked like they like we got like field
trips through the Opera so a whole bunch
of like cholos at the Opera it was cool
how come you went I just did school and
I just [ __ ] you so your is it once you
turn 18 you have to go there no wasn't
you could be younger players just
expelled out of the other school or so
way behind that the only way to catch up
was to you know going because there you
get credits like super quick you know
yeah yeah for showing up yeah yeah we
gotta have elective credits for like
dressing up for Halloween a role that
class appreciation class music I
appreciate that they give you in that
class if you keep your shoes on yeah get
me for her like ninth grade with the two
holding hands yeah lunch my friend loves
more than
glass like that and that fool I heard
something look in the hallway he was
being chased by the teacher to go back
in the class oh yeah he's your hero some
girl I mentioned before keep trying roll
the Armenian Russian chick with little
arms he goes who shut up to my home and
here are me hahahaha no she took all
that Bush used to call her our
men-at-arms writer well why are they
small just cuz they're like to raise
arms oh my god baby do her home laying
down shut up terribly Oh Garcia was so
full to a like the large cell Mandor
Frank Garcia with her jerking off
watching a podcast Kilroy Was Here Come
on your 1950 get ready watching what dr.
Petch about World War to World War II he
real world book IRA the liquor store
everybody went to around my area was in
East LA
Luke's Dukes liquor did you go yeah on
city terrace because they never carted
to the city so don't card to everybody
will go there and it was like these
Asian owners that owned the liquor store
we will always go there before now again
everybody so liquored brought your kids
oh yeah you know yeah we took notes from
our not from my mom but my friend's mom
smoked and she would give us a note to
go down to the keyhole which is this
place in Dayton the keyhole keyhole and
we used to steal a lemonhead candies
because they're right there but when
you're checking out but they would
accept a note
give please sell my daughter whatever
pack of whatever she smoked and then
they would give it to us
damn every Friday I will go to Mario's
market and buy a 40 ounce er and go with
my baby mama before she of my baby mama
to a Harlem Airport and do the dirty
deed
while pervert watched us whatever just
chilly right there bro and there was
like the dude behind her with happiness
bakka bro if he's gonna shoot us
holla back park and a lot of perverse
bro I were walking what time we're
walking with my cousins
and we just left the park to go buy ice
cream yeah across the street and then we
saw this man jerking off watching us
like we passed by him and he didn't put
it away bro he was jerking off
are you [ __ ] brother that's a trap bro
to see if you want to go into the car
yeah see if you like it yeah that's what
you're trying to do yeah I don't think
there's one kid who's gonna pass by and
go I want to go in there fresh cheese
burger a whopper
impossible operator probably ah its
progressive Robin what have been the
toughest part about being a yo comic um
getting things pulled out just getting
better you know just definitely going
from like sucking in the first year to
like keep them telling you just keep
kidding about that part bro the sucking
part well yeah that was a big part and
then that was like a lot of open mics
are like like [ __ ] over 70% you got
to pay for them dance and then when I
started it was like [ __ ] 70% you
didn't have to pay for yeah so it just
makes it harder to like keep hitting
like a lot of spots in a day if any
money going on yeah comes about it you
do open minds right yeah Oh Tommy time
yeah do you think those people in your
story or people and you started like who
are doing open mic who would who are
doing them comedy already longer than
you put this to live in the open mic
life there's a lot of those people did
you get out I know I got out I know I
got out because my friends were doing
open mic with me got out first
I saw success right away cuz I remember
I was going to open mics and then they
were I was stopped seeing people like I
stopped seeing Jamie Kennedy and you
were blowing up yeah hard what makes
what person you think stay they're not
seen success or not I mean not knowing
or afraid to leave the big that the
no area with little funniest not knowing
how the business side of Comedy Works I
know I had a message Booker's or out
what's it called hustle you know and
they just stick there and these people
have become superstars in the open mic
scene I've seen it you know like the if
I can people pod on the open mic like
that's what I don't want that's out of
it well I think what happens there well
they might not have a gig to go to but
this is their gig it's their regular gig
then it that's what it becomes and then
you see those guys who've been doing it
for 10 15 years and they say even though
if they're not at the open mic they're
at a bar which is a workout room and
they're trying to kill with that
material that they've been doing for 10
15 you can trying and you can't get
fired from comedy it's not like your
numbers are low whatever you you can
still be part of the scene you are
you'll be like going to like a hang out
at a bar at a comedy show and you still
feel you're part of the scene you know
but that's another mistake though that
people make is they feel if they're
hanging out they feel like they're doing
something to bring their not work no
more Oh at least I am there are a lot of
those guys and girls hanging out and
they're just hanging out and then they
at the end of the night did you really
did you go up tonight you know that like
I was do a comedian hanging out my show
be at open mic yeah you shouldn't be
here hanging no that's not gonna get
nothing for me yeah give it right home
people hanging out like at the comedy so
never go up and as opposed to like
exploring you know like they know whose
father you yeah so yeah I definitely go
to the commerce store only really after
I've already danced and look yeah oh
yeah come for potluck I was there uh two
days ago for pilot you go to hang out
after you've hit some open mic I feel
way better about it everywhere I went
out they went numb shuttle Flaco happy
birthday Flacco hey happy birthday for
all before oh no I was 50 when I met him
live with a little iron heart Alicia
unplug him
here's a peacemaker yeah everything
broke ah I get to charge it up every
hour he's a robot from West world and
given that the battery died ago that
fool posted a post to death morning he
said that up hey man I'm gonna get back
into it now man fry you guy who never
booked me man continue not booking me
and I wrote out this bro
forget it well you should do bro what's
the communist or go to the potluck and
get to know other people out of a small
pond you're in your [ __ ] you know if
you complain about that book you gonna
leave yeah comedy leave that area nobody
gonna book you know more leave that
scene just start another scene it seems
bigger than ever man like for me I
remember uh I felt like if you felt like
nobody in a book you would acquit I do
my yeah boy I remember like for a while
I feel like I burn myself out from do
you know I guess I easy did I [ __ ]
for a bit mics and I and because I would
wait like three hours and only three
people be there so I was like you know
go get drunk - what opium Ickes yeah yes
one get off I was like the worst arrow
and I was like chubby Rizzo do the kill
oh we're not that cool a con yeah
talking [ __ ] about America they say
ebrill yeah so so Flaco I know you're
saying though but you're right he should
leave because he's a one-man he's his
job is him it's not that who's around
there he can take that a lot of people
who even who are who are not as how
unhealthy earth block will feel that way
like all over the book you me bro nobody
can you cuz you're not out there nobody
know who you are I don't know you were
the only no you passed the 6:05 also
people do do you yeah there's so many
opportunities you do videos your podcast
if I would always put him on a ballot
walk coyotes and not going to a lap back
to the Comedy Store I would have never
met Paul Rodriguez and never never may
Russell Peters and never never like
Angela Johnson yeah see that's what the
food gotta go out there nobody's taking
on the road because you don't know
nobody yeah yeah and like even George
when George came out of prison he was
like I'm doing this a different way this
time and he went to the comedy store and
he had never hung out at the college
before and then he became part of that
crowd and it was like I don't need those
bar rooms as my only
form of small spots or whatever and now
he's like podcast people said walk can't
do this bro that's with a job in the
daytime oh yeah we're gonna say gas and
he [ __ ] drives over there though the
pocket comes back what's your Excuse
Europe yeah you're a brand you gotta
like everything and I got it like I said
another this part kid I was on man
it's like this bro just a really like
comedians out here man is that one
Johnny of kids you know what can you
work and what can you do for comedy bro
how many can do for you
yeah well he's gonna do nothing oh yeah
I thought what comedy can do for you but
what you could do for comedy yeah cuz
company they're gonna help you bro you
finally gonna put in the work you gonna
do everything you can to like stand
there you know yeah definitely a podcast
and shake their you know what about me
you can start by doing them when your
brother show don't put it all caps only
idiot to that that's not like
desperateness it's something desperation
and then doing all your posts in a
five-minute period also but they'll put
everybody on the flyer nobody's here
buying a flyer put their name that's
your flyer brother have people I've
never seen before I don't want to go
yeah I see common sense you but I know
this kinda common sense but the fan
knows yeah they're gonna look up these
people go with a minute okay you never
been a [ __ ] now what is face on a photo
now you can look up on Google now it
before you know I can lie but some
people just can't be to be on a flyer
yeah I know I did I remember when I
first me on fire like [ __ ] dude this is
it i'ma show my friends I showed my mom
my first flyer cuz I do printed it
island and I was like man look I was
like like a year into comedy he was like
yeah a year mr. beebe talked about
garcia for telling the truth I was in
there I was there the other time when I
was cold a spark dude what if I do news
at least the active Apocalypto because I
don't double here's a little baby those
inside that tunnel give me the mic
you're a monkey Lisa I got no shows you
do
I Naples reporter now right oh I know
I'm not you a label do porn yeah we we
feel more so sometime right we film
ourselves to see you we do good you know
actually you should put your leg in
sweat list thank you serious you watch
it you see how your game oh you can see
how couples do that it goes those to
watch like that though to critique no I
just severely this is a good time on so
let's say you break up tomorrow what
happens to those videos
I have a mom those videos blog you
should take a money should put them on
the bottom of your phone cuz everything
you show a photo I can see what Johnny
finds a bro oh [ __ ] you start wearing
your clothes more like the old one he
was all torn up radio you keep it yeah
Johnny lose wheel bro no Washington one
Steve watching him on stage he was
tennis deal with his legs together he do
like an exclamation point like a little
like a little bat yeah little skinny
legs bro like mermaid Leto
like a shark well he has the legs of
somebody who used to be big yes
like big boy yeah yeah he's like yeah
yeah no you know the thing about the
needs going into her that's uh when
you're a kid the way you used to sit
that's is okay here we go
fans now see there now all your lousy
dinner or the video
the video went viral right already yeah
yeah how much do they have all 200,000 I
think it's got like a hundred fifty
thousand and then I know another page
shared it I think all together has like
over two hundred
oh so simple to shoot it was just people
I just like that it was very always
saying it was very creative like even
the water bottle as your monocle yeah
yeah
no more low budget look like the funnier
was yeah we went to a badass a vegan
restaurant in Killeen is called
California cravings California cravings
if you look if we're in that area by
Fort Hood they got some special food
Esquith our vegan there playing Debbie
dev there no no right no if we had
ordered opps
he ordered he ordered I did three style
fries with those treats a lot like fries
it's funny I just saw a recipe first of
my little day fries I was like I'm gonna
make this at home just corn with fries
it's like they a little thick corn like
the corn and a cup how they make it in
Texas so it's not from and you pour it
on the fries do you think it was good
I'm putting it on top of fries and
you're gonna eat it broke into that
Gargamel with polio what's your
Instagram all right follow you yeah you
guys follow me Roger Lopez comedy on
Instagram and I have a podcast name
called Roger that you guys can go on
YouTube thank you but do new for like
three months now yeah so it's you
talking or you have guests no I have
guests yeah I have like this whole like
creative group we call channel three
window and I have like some of them on
to like you know talked with me that way
it's just not me talking boring but
sometimes I'll do like a solo episode
like I did a solo one on my way to
George Paris stories his podcast oh I
did like him before I went to the park
and then after when I was [ __ ] up oh I
was walking I parked my dad's car I
[ __ ] walked back to the crib I was
like [ __ ] up talking into my phone it
was like five minutes just Muller uh
that [ __ ] was so bad
did you ghost your club with them no now
we use [ __ ] Lisa drank smoked it was
cool
what attached to be 25 I know can you
imagine be 20 well you were kind of in
the scene but I don't think the scene I
was sober when I first time a comedy for
the 10 years then I fell off when able
to party in well well you weren't you
fell off the wagon but you had already
gotten on when I start doing stand-up
comedy
I finally doing no drugs I never saw
anyone get high I never saw coke I never
seen anything yeah once I start smoking
weed bro wolves came out every ha ha ha
I really what half of my first week yeah
they were small to run man they never
smelled like weed you know yeah and then
I start doing coke [ __ ] cocodrilos
over here calling at 4:00 in the morning
who's up why yeah brother I remember
hanging out at the wall coyotes in my
it's in my downtime we [ __ ] here now
we're doing we've hooked up in a side me
George Perez and other fools bro damn
bro I smoked Primo's dog Coco Puffs
3 Obama we did bumps yeah we get after
one yeah man I was down bro [ __ ] rank
yep for 2 other than sleep another two
days because I wasn't come to kind of
gather and want to party continue you
know yeah I can't have you want beer sit
down bro
I want everybody send me one beer like
we have ever had one beer that's I don't
drink because I know people pick up a
club under sound I don't sound how
people can just drink to taste the
alcohol me I gotta get I got yeah I want
to get [ __ ] up you know I'll get
[ __ ]
yeah I just me I just want like if I
start drinking like everyone gonna start
drinking and then I'm gonna go to
smoking cigarettes and then looking for
coke right away I don't know pass now
when I drink that's my whole goal when I
drink probably black now recently yeah
yeah that guy I just be drinking tequila
man like iDream o stielike still
reserved to eleven so changing over does
the mr. Rizzuto bro bro kill yourself
because some alcohols affect you
differently tequila with Felipe becomes
a whole different person yeah it makes
me it like I like beer or even know who
I am
wine oh my god yeah it's a whole
different drunk I know like we say we
own you around I owe you see you saw
people doing cocaine the only drug I saw
was like I rode my cousin dropped the
crystal meth and from the whole family
and he picked it up and they real quick
like what was that but we're like yes
gotta worry that's what they do my
cousin do it in high school were so bad
really we see ditch school then we go to
the the [ __ ] the river the [ __ ]
watch and we're they were tagging the
walls one time by the wash and like
there's these apartment complexes across
the street and I'm doing you call the
cops we all ran and we're in class and
we hear like the principal call my
cousin cuz he left this [ __ ] backpack
with his how they got over oh this is
the one who dropped the meth
yeah yeah who lost him go do the old
lady yeah yeah that one I want to this
you don't want her to go at the mall
head yeah yeah I wrote do we got caught
a podcast second I know not part of it
it's all part of the scene bro ticket of
someone's car yeah we got caught
shoplifting at Target one time feeling
what CD hahaha technics
a little finger skill yeah do we went to
the same spot for three days in a row
exact buy this so easy man I know I got
caught because they [ __ ] easy you
coming back somewhere people are stupid
I will take everything time closed so
summary score say people who saw us go
before were seen from freshman year so
like ever I we were just ditching summer
school and we're summers yeah
so the third day genius so Thursday
we're walking out target right we
[ __ ] we got out already it was
smoking so easy and it's gotta bring the
close to us we walk back into
little office and the guys like all
right guys we saw you just just admit
what's going on and I who you you have
the back way it was my cousin who
thought you had the back we were just
stuffing everything inside like just
tell us we have we hiding a camera and I
was like just tell the truth a scared
man do they make fun of me the whole
time so they let us go because he had
the backpack and we were waiting outside
target like oh they're gonna let us go
cuz they let us go we're out there for
like 20 minutes and we see my aunt
driving in a car like a [ __ ] run into
the bushes I go home I go home I go home
right and I'm like my mom's upstairs Mui
cuz we're usually come after school so
I'm like just downstairs like like
putting my thumb's like I get all scared
em I'm was laid on this table vide on uh
he'll be here and they're like she came
down a guy like Antonio you'll be here
do a now we're like what's going on I
know you just broke that mom I told her
what happened cuz my actor called her
and then it was crazy
we weren't to confess could they have
like done something still how much did
you steal how much was it worth 30 bucks
see that's the thing about Felipe he
knows all the rules about what they can
prosecute you for probably I would say
one because you know you're not you
cannot get like taken to jail I they
might call your mom yeah you fake number
like he knows that racket to know that
but I was scared that I [ __ ] didn't
do bad [ __ ] anymore I went to I remember
because I I did so much that I couldn't
they couldn't give me credit in class
and I was like I told lady let me just
being here I'll do the work for free
honest I'm just scared of me out there
and I didn't get any credit for a beat
dude I did my homework any any credit I
just want to be in there I just I was so
scared their self-imposed in-school
suspension yeah yeah
that's up anymore so your brother you
could tell your brother to you know
Dooku's commit crimes after that and
where he stabbed so so I mean yeah he
stabbed somebody then he went to like a
[Laughter]
poke somebody then he went to another
martini Casey yeah yeah man that school
is ghetto do it was school surprise the
ham Bros a lot of Asian gangsters a lot
of hugging Mexican gangsters dude it was
a crazy yeah I remember like there was
like this day was it June 6 of 2006
those cuz it was six six six
there's like flowers going around our
tools are making and punk rockers we're
gonna [ __ ] up all the emos this day like
what the [ __ ] I was like the whole thing
six six six oh they're gonna [ __ ] up all
the emos I walk you rockers hahaha
what's up rock you wouldn't know that
people say I'm the main cake we got
shows coming up fool
Naples that's it sound how's it brother
Riverside I don't have any show sorry
I'm doing business here you see I go
after you commander Jim what's up fools
shots will do vitória had a baby who
watch my show while the show that I'm on
hand to fight imma be on him what
whenever it comes out tell him the truth
bro yeah I remember once I was stealing
you your cars with the homies like from
my neighborhood Toys R Us so like we
would like I'll grab a pack and they
would all be like are dispersed so we
dispersed in the in the Toys R Us right
just be taking that [ __ ] so I see the
homies after I you know I already took
it and so I go outside of the Toys R Us
and I see three of them getting like
talked to by the security you ran and
then uh I was I was about to say what's
up like a dumbass but then one of my
home is he just like who just like he
waved me to like just go
go and I just [ __ ] him man I got the
crib I got lucky I remember I was uh
when I worked at RadioShack I think I'm
one of the reasons why they went out of
business because everybody's is still
there let's be realistic here do you
know the brands yeah and everybody's
steal from RadioShack goes crazy
that's a bet whatever by further DJ DJ
quick do I remember there was one time
this one guy stole a [ __ ] laptop in
front of me in front of everybody
this guy was weird he went in there he
kept like looking around and I think I
was just like on drugs he kept asking to
look at this laptop I kept hanging on
handling them this laptop like three
times and when the last time you grab
the laptop and he was looking like this
with his size he was like like this
guy's weird and then he just [ __ ]
went like this and he started running
out the door I chased after him for some
reason I don't know why I [ __ ] steal
from this place and then I would say he
ran away I would say call if I am well
it's crazy
and man when you think like when you get
caught shoplifting when they finally
there man and then like how you see your
aunt you know it's on how you know it's
gonna tell your mom already yeah that's
a great thing about how never hung out
with my cousin's when I was a kids I
never had that yeah I never had that uh
that built-in snitch or whatever that
were that ability to you know what your
aunt finds out something and it's gonna
tell your mom yeah yeah I never had that
experience I imagined before phones took
a long time bro in Mexico City that's
all my cousins are over there so I said
when I was 12 but with my first time and
their rahuri
actually my dad's from Oaxaca my mom's
from Mexico City all right dad did he
grow up rich oh no oh I didn't know no
because there's a guy that was his
exchange student that lived with him we
had exchanged to live on Mexico City
more in the projects bro that was rich
Brock he was really nice Patti kid to
live with other projects yeah man
yeah well so fool yes shows coming up
right yeah the bangbang rooms 10 10th
I'm doing this other show in this
Wednesday or just check my Instagram but
it'll be on their new comic Martin Rizzo
check out our video la tarea in real
life and yeah man who podcasts yeah man
what's up fools charts with realtor had
his son Tomas